yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm revealing how the
ending to the predator was completely
changed plus all the other deleted
scenes you never got to see of course
I'll be talking spoilers so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet let's
kick off with the scrapped ending that
would have featured Arnold
Schwarzenegger touch making a surprise
comeback to set up the predator sequel
in a completely different way to what we
saw in the final film in blacks original
2016 screenplay after McKenna Rory and
Casey's final fight with the ultimate
predator a chopper turns up as it lands
we discover it's none other than
Schwarzenegger who's described in the
script as having a face that's haunted
and etched by pain Dutch asked them to
come with him and Mackenna son Rory acid
he should go to Dutch smiles or replies
especially you than the screen cuts to
black in this alternate ending Dutch
wood also revealed that a war has
started
it's not stated explicitly but it's
heavily implied that there's some kind
of secret war going on between humanity
and the Predators I think we could see a
remnant of this idea in this next scene
which shows McKenna looking up and
saying come get us mother however
although that scene was shot it was
deleted from the final film now I
suspect many fans of the original movie
would have loved a Schwarzenegger cameo
but he turned down the role because he
said that after reading the script he
didn't like it and the part was too
small
Schwarzenegger also seemed more
interested in being available for James
Cameron's Terminator 6 where he does
have a significant role Shane Black has
said he understands why Schwarzenegger
rejected the role but added that the
studio didn't want the new movie to be
centered around the ant has returned to
the franchise and instead wanted to
introduce a new cast the scripts
alternate ending would have been
stronger in my opinion and the predator
killer suit reveal which felt tacked on
and totally didn't fit the rest of the
movie in fact that moment in the final
film felt more like a Marvel post-credit
scene for an Iron Man movie because the
way the tech wrapped itself around the
scientists body screamed Tony Stark's
nanotech suit to me also I wonder why
the studio didn't think of simply
replacing Schwarzenegger as cameo with
say Danny Glover from predator 2 Black's
original script also reveals another
deleted section from the last act in the
film that we never got to see in the
original story there was a group of
friends
predators hidden away in area 52 we've
been working with the secret government
organization to help defend the earth
against the incoming wave of upgrade
predators in fact they were actually
going to fight alongside McKenna's team
and you can see these friendly predators
decked out in military camouflage
uniform and on set photos trailers also
show footage from those tank scenes
which never made it into the final movie
and in the original script the Upgrade
predator had also been tasked with
tracking down and killing those friendly
predators tied in with the original
story about predators working with the
government was edward james olmos as
character who ended up getting chopped
out of the movie almost played a
four-star general over sterling kate
brown's character and it seems like he
was going to be the real big villain of
the movie according to Shane black
almost his character was trying to
recruit the first predator that arrived
on earth and it communicated with him
the actor was due to appear in two
scenes but they were both deleted when
black decided he had one bad guy too
many in the story and so sterling K
Brown took over as a chief human
antagonist by the way one of the movies
almost as well known for is Blade Runner
where his character is known for making
little origami unicorns so wonder if
Black included that little tinfoil
unicorn in the predator as a kind of
Easter Egg to Blade Runner as Olmos was
originally supposed to be in this movie
the Upgrade predator was also gained to
unleash even more predator hybrids than
the dogs we saw in the film we could
have ended up seeing predators with
multiple arms which to date have only
appeared in the comics and there were
even going to be hybrid predator spiders
the predator killer ending in the final
movie is also part of a huge story
change that was made when Shane black
decided to go back and almost completely
reshoot the entire third act the
predator killer suit is revealed to be a
piece of technology that the first
predator we see in the movie brought to
earth is a gift to help humanity defend
itself against the upgrade predators who
want to move in and colonize the planet
because it's getting warmer the problem
with this new ending is that it doesn't
match up very well with what happened
earlier in the film if the fugitive
predator came to earth to help humans
out then why was it slaughtering anyone
it could lay its hands on right from the
moment it landed on earth another reason
why Shane black says he we shot almost
the entire third act is that while
reviewing for
she thought the fight scenes with the
predator in daylight didn't look very
good
black explained that when they started
to do their effects work it looks kind
of cheap in a way it didn't really feel
like a big expensive movie when the
Predators were just running around in
daylight like that
so black managed to convince Fox to
reshoot much of the final act in the
dark which must have been pretty
expensive and is likely why the film's
release was put back from February to
September 2018 although I can see blacks
point I have to wonder whether this was
really a good idea because many people
have complained about it being really
hard to figure out what was going on in
the fight scenes at the end the
geography of the action as a cut between
characters was very confusing and the
darkness of the footage definitely
didn't help that funnily enough this
isn't the first time that similar
complaints have surfaced in the predator
franchise one of the many criticisms
levelled at alien versus Predator
Requiem is that much of the action
happens in the dark after a power outage
making it incredibly difficult to
distinguish what's going on in the
action scenes one very widely publicized
deleted scene happened when Olivia Munn
discovered one of her co actors Stephen
wildest regal was a convicted sex
offender the scene in question cast
regal in the part of a stranger who
tries to chat up man's character Casey
in a dog park it was certainly a
sensible move to delete the scene in
question what was lost with the cut was
a longer scene introducing Munz
characters someone who doesn't take any
nonsense from anyone and it also would
have foreshadowed a little more her
later connection with one of the
Predator dogs so I'm guessing the scene
would have been Rashad if the issue had
come to light earlier whether these
alternate endings stories and deleted
scenes would have made the movie any
better is debatable although I have
enjoyed some of black's movies in the
past i think his approach to this
predator movie was flawed it's on record
that when black came onboard the project
as writer and director one of his
conditions was that everything had to be
bigger a bigger budget a bigger scope
more characters more predators more of
everything and i think that led to too
much being crammed into the story on top
of that because there were huge story
changes and extensive reshoots some
crucial aspects just don't make real
sense anymore such as the actions and
motives of the first predator we see in
the film and then
maybe because the whole thing is such a
hodgepodge of original and reshot
footage combined with editing that feels
too fast and frenetic it means that
moments like the death of sterling K
Browns character happens so quickly that
if you blinked you probably missed it so
would you prefer the original ending to
the predator and would you have liked to
have seen any of these deleted scenes in
the final film leave your thoughts in
the comments below and let me know
whether you enjoyed the movie tapleft -
check out my recent nun videos with a
review of the ending + deleted scenes or
tap write my full deleted scenes
playlist if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to leave a thumbs up and a share
would be hugely appreciated - thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
gay movie lovers